the hype is literally off the charts as
the most anticipated flashback of one
piece at God Valley is in full swing
from Prime GARP Roger Rox and crew
Everybody and more so stay tuned for
this most hype of chapters chill the
parking within and smash that like
button if you enjoy seeing these one
piece reviews and want to keep them
coming make this the video you join the
knock up by subscribing and hitting that
notification Bell so you don't miss
future one piece videos and updates by
clicking that one button you can help us
reach our insane goal of hitting 2
million subscribers on YouTube for which
I'd be eternally grateful and now
without further Ado let's jump into It
spoilers and all so this chapter is
called kumachi a nickname for Kuma by
jinny and Zoro is on the cover request
for this one which is good news for Zoro
stands like me last chapter we left off
with kid Kuma going through horrible
conditions like this is more tragic than
Shakespearean Place him and his loving
parents became slaves because it got out
that his dad had the blood of the
buccaneer race a race which which also
happens to spread the story of NAA
someone who will come to save slaves and
take them under the sun to the Freedom
of the Seas the drum rhythm of his
heartbeat brings joy and laughter but
this idealistic story was just opposed
to a very harsh reality Kuma's mom died
first and then his father for making
noise while trying to cheer his son up
about his mother's death it was so
sudden and horrific probably one of the
most messed up moments in one piece to
date not like we needed more reasons not
to like the celestial dragons but this
is up there with the biggest then Kuma
got taken to God Valley as a sort of
star of the slaves that will be hunted
down because of his rare Buccaneer jeans
but then ran into a young ianov and
jinny and jinny who although shares a
lot of similarities to Luffy as I
mentioned last chapter seems to be being
set up as Bonnie's mom in this chapter
even more so which does make sense since
Bonnie also has a lot of the same
characteristics that Luffy does too Kuma
wanted to end his life at this point but
Ivanov came with a motivational speech
about choosing life and then we get into
this chapter that picks up from there
but gets way crazier into the chapter
itself in the crazy hunting event
appears to be starting again crazy to
see how much figer land Garling looks
like Shanks in this flashback definitely
lends Credence to all the shanks as a
Celestial Dragon theories but I'm very
interested to see how his character Arc
will in the end either Embrace or push
back against that identity we also see
some new holy Knights one prince-like
young guy a girl with her eyes covered
by her hat looking very ready for the
hunt looking lips and everything and a
guy with a gas mask and the connotations
of that one are scary will he be using
poison gas on the slaves in the games or
something either way you don't want to
get near a dude with a gas mask but we
really get the epicness underway where
everyone else starts arriving first we
see GARP enjoying a vacation the visual
treats are next level in this chapter as
we'll really get into in a bit but even
here just seeing Prime GARP listening to
music on a beach chair and smiling like
Luffy is awesome then he gets
interrupted by Kong he was on vacation
has no idea what's happening on God
Valley but he goes because he heard
Roger maybe on the move too so cool to
see that GARP took so much note of Roger
at this point going to be crazy to see
that much talked about moment of them
fighting against rocks together Ivanov
and Kuma create a plan to escape God
Valley by taking the devil fruit prizes
from the slave hunt tournament and using
them cool idea and crazy to think that
that's even an option first Shanks takes
the sun god naika fruit and now this
these guys are definitely not good at
not getting their devil fruit stolen
Kuma is even a kid at this point he
still man as we know based on the future
and as we'll see to get one it's like
with Shanks where you can at least be
like well what are you going to do with
Shanks can't mess with that Legend oh
yeah you want to end the Paramount War I
no problem it's just too bad Prime
Shanks wasn't there to just end the god
Valley incident as well and yes I'm half
joking but only half we also find out
that Jenny is an expert at stealing and
using den den Mushi so she's the one who
leaked the Celestial Dragon events
information to the Pirates 2 weeks ago
that's why Rock and Roger Pirates came
to God Valley crazy how much of a role
she played in this historic event we
even see a cute cat and its paw and a
scary dragon image to show the powers of
the devil fruits which I thought was a
nice touch we're told that among the
prizes here as discussed are kaido's
future devil fruit the U noi and Kuma's
future devil fruit the niku niku noi aka
the paramia poaw fruit so clearly kid
Kuma does succeed in his affir mention
plan to take at least that one although
Ivanov as we know won't succeed in take
the other at one point we even see that
Kuma has an arrow on the bullseye Mark
drawn on his back but the dude is just
acting like it's not even there the dude
is such a boss even at this young age
he's been through a lot and it really
adds to the weight of his entire
character in retrospect but back to the
Rocks pirates for now as we'll remember
kaido got his legendary fruit on God
Valley with big mom's help so we'll see
exactly how that went down just so many
Legends crisscrossing at the same place
and time right here it's everything us
fans could ever wish for so many of
these panels would make for perfect
colored posters to put on our walls
since they are so epic we see a younger
kaido with no full beard just some
stubble which definitely seems to be a
popular pirate fashion thing we see
Shiki a young big mom a young Miss
bucking AKA Stussy hanging off and get
this Whitebeard shoulder no less we'll
definitely get into that more later
again but yes she looks like her clone
so the idea of Weevil being whitebeard's
true son is looking true and trer I've
been telling you guys it's revealed that
gloriosa or Elder nonon former Empress
of the Kuja tribe Generations before boa
hanok was also a rocks pirate it's crazy
that this pirate crew can get even more
star studded but yeah we're adding an
empress to the mix as well now it just
doesn't stop with the Rocks Pirates we
see all these old Legends together and I
must say a lot of attractive woman on
this crew and yes that includes big mom
maybe we never thought we'd say that
about big mom but here we are anyways as
if all this wasn't enough hype past
revolutionaries GARP Gods Knights rocks
Pirates now we also see the Roger
Pirates and Roger has the iconic straw
hat with him crazy how much that thing
traveled when you think about it I never
thought about it that much but man that
thing's old and seen some crazy
legendary stuff if that straw had could
talk but yes we get another epic panel
of Roger crew with Roger also having
stubble rather than his mustache he
looks young and has the iconic straw hat
on his back rather than on his head the
dark King rley is there too although I
must say that the Rocks PIR panel is
probably my favorite of the chapter
everyone is in charging forward for
battle mode Garling is there too such a
star studded Battlefield it's insane we
see Prime GARP there pulling up his
sleeve in characteristic fashion showing
off his guns and charging and in the
middle of all this Kuma and iono got
their hands on their respective fruits
however big mom arrives and quickly
takes kaido's future fruit from iano so
think about it we could have had a
bigheaded dragon floating around
destroying cities with its Winks if she
was just moments late but as we know
this makes sense since she's the reason
kaido got the devil fruit that currently
in the flashback Ivanov is after and
again crazy seeing big mom and even
Stussy like this and how unlike fine
wine these women aged as we might have
expected big mom is obviously stronger
than Ivanov so Ivanov ain't getting that
fruit back to eat however Kuma surprise
surprise manages to eat his pop off
Route just in time before Saturn himself
suddenly shows up and in the same panel
where we realize he's there he hit Kuma
Saturn is in human form but with dark
flame and lightning effects around him
Kuma says the world is not normal why is
someone like you born into Power while I
was born as a slave if I had any power I
would use it to help people like NAA did
end quote a beautiful sentiment from The
Young and idealistic Kuma who suffered
so much for his age and then Saturn
being evil to the Bon says that's why
your kind must be erased end quote for
him it seems he wants the world
government to rule and these ideas of
naika and helping people only threaten
that rule that's why people like Kuma
the revolutionaries myths history and
Luffy are so dangerous in their eyes it
seems like they want to maintain their
uninterrupted and unquestioned rule or
who knows maybe they're even more messed
up than that and just want people to
suffer but I always try to figure out
the motivations of the villains in these
stories let me know your thoughts in the
comments why are the elders like this
what is their top goal and why perhaps
the most hyped thing is that Roger and
Rox exchange words now we don't see
zeb's face yet but he does speak Roger
tries to reason with him saying stop at
rocks while Rock says don't get in my
way Roger always cool to see dudes like
this talking like they know each other
well like they have history and
everything of course we are not exactly
sure what Roger is trying to stop
specifically from these spoilers but we
know they will end up fighting and if
the stories are true Roger and GARP will
end up teaming up but still trying to
realize why Roger would seemingly team
up with GARP I find it hard to believe
that he just want to keep the celestial
dragons safe against zebek so looking
forward to figuring out the truth we
don't see the whole God Valley incident
at least not yet but we see the
different factions arriving here and we
skip to sorb Kingdom to which Kuma
Ivanov and jinny Escape we get some
insights into their life there Ivanov
leaves but the other two stay behind
Kuma works hard with a smile on his face
cutting wood and carrying it with Jenny
on his back too when some kids bully him
Jenny shows them what's up a funny
Dynamic considering how much bigger he
is than Jenny but he's a gentle giant so
people take advantage then Kuma even
helps the kids by appearing to push out
their pain with his devil fruit Powers
sure they have some challenges but it's
a happy idyllic life at the same time
especially since they know how cruel the
world can be Kuma and Jenny are eating
and crying together in happiness Kuma
says Jenny has a big appetite and he
uses a word similar to Bonnie's nickname
definitely suggesting that she is in
most likelihood Bonnie's mom a very nice
scene to leave off on and although it
didn't last forever it's so nice to see
Kuma experiencing this window of
Happiness considering how hard his early
life and then later life will be and
that is the end of this chapter so great
to see these Legends together at the
most hype incident but hoping Oda
returns there after teasing us and not
that we just follow Kuma now at least
give us ze's face Oda just come on but
there so much to love about this chapter
at the same time even small stuff from
actually seeing these Legends back in
the day charging with their Crews seeing
Roger with no mustache kind of with
floral pants and no full beard thinking
he's future Shanks or something Miss
buckin has more expressive Expressions
compared to her clone Stussy and she's
sitting on Whitebeard shoulders what was
I telling you guys all this time Weevil
is looking more and more like
whitebeard's actual Son by the chapter
at this point he just probably needs a
glow up for us to take it more seriously
but let me know if you agree with me and
also think that Weevil really is
Whitebeard Sun but that is it for this
one no break next week if you enjoyed
getting more info on rockd zebic and his
crew then you definitely don't want to
miss my video on all rocks pirates and
their powers explain link on screen
right now like And subscribe to help us
reach our insane goal of 2 million
subscribers on YouTube and I'll see you
in the next one